cheer up Spyder fans spider-man's
ejection from the MCU may be short-lived
according to a new rumor started by
youtuber TiVo Marvel Studios parent
company Disney and Spidey film rights
holder Sony Pictures are back at the
bargaining table trying to work out the
details of a new deal that would keep
the wall crawler in the MCU for a long
long time the unconfirmed report says
that inside sources at Marvel have given
TiVo the skinny on new negotiations
between the two studios who recently
failed to reach an agreement to extend
their shared custody arrangement of a
Spidey again we stress that this report
is completely unconcerned but it would
be pretty exciting if the rumors are
accurate according to TiVo the new deal
being discussed would involve no fewer
than six feature film starring current
spider-man actor Tom Holland and an
option for a seventh who wouldn't want
seven more spider films one of these as
yet imaginary features would service a
direct sequel to this year's spider-man
far from home and would conclude the
story of Peter Parker's high school
years an additional three solo vehicles
would focus on Parker navigating the ups
and downs of college life while
contending with a growing array of
supervillains but wait there's more the
other two films proposed in the deal
according to TiVo synonymous and
unconfirmed sources would be the fifth
and sixth Avengers movies which have not
been announced by Marvel Studios either
and in true fanfiction fashion these
sources also report that the plan is for
one of those team-up flex to depict
Parker meeting up with one of his oldest
allies Johnny Storm the Fantastic Four's
Human Torch is it likely that Marvel and
Sony have plan that far ahead and those
plans won't easily change not really but
technically this meeting would be
possible thanks to Disney's recent
acquisition of the film and television
rights to the x-men and Fantastic Four
as a youngest member of Marvel's first
family Johnny Storm as a first hero to
offer counsel to Spidey when the latter
was first embarking on his
crime-fighting career way back in the
amazing spider-man issue 3 during a
speech at Peter school Johnny Storm
spoke about the virtues of never giving
up it was a message that hits home with
Parker who had just suffered his first
humiliating defeat at the hands of
Doctor Octopus inspired by storms words
Parker saddled up for a rematch with Doc
Ock and this time he won TiVo's
mysterious sources also offered up one
final tidbit Marvel has allegedly come
back to the table with a couple of
bargaining chips that would incentivize
Sony to get the deal done
the deal would reportedly stipulate that
Disney who holds the television rights
to spider-man would allow Sony to move
forward with their TV universe based
around the wall crawler and his pals
Chris Miller and Phil Lord who
co-produced uske winning animated
feature spider-man into the spider verse
for Sony Pictures animation have been
tasked with developing the slate of
live-action series which presumably are
dead in the water until Disney and Sony
Hammer alt a new deal second the Disney
is said to be interested in integrating
Sony's Marvel characters which include
venom and Morbius the living vampire
into the MCU
the Tom Hardy starring venom was a
resounding commercial success raking in
eight hundred and fifty-six million
dollars of the worldwide box office
considering that far from home recently
became the highest-grossing spider-man
movie ever and Sony Pictures best
box-office performer of all time the
idea of folding venom into the MCU has
to be a tantalizing one it would
virtually guarantee an even more stellar
global take for the lethal protectors
second solo vehicle which could
conceivably feature spider-man next time
around once again and we can't say this
enough this report is in no way
confirmed but it's not so difficult to
imagine that talks could begin again
fingers crossed that evo sources aren't
yanking our webs they'll be here to
report on any official announcements
that may come down from Marvel and Sony
until then the biggest question remains
Peter you still with us check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the Bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]